hey guys so a short disclaimer before we
start the video um obviously this is
being released in October and a sort of
semi parts of the shocktober thing and
that is because um it's a followup to my
previous episode on Jin possession which
fits I think pretty neatly into that
category and also because the the video
you know in Broad Strokes deals with
with gin possession in different ways
but with that said I do not want to give
the impression that Zod itself is
something scary or spooky right I
realized this as I was making the video
that maybe people will sort of
misunderstand that I don't want to
misrepresent Zar or Zar practitioners as
being spooky or scary this is an
important spiritual thing for many
people in this region and so I just felt
like I need to point out that I do not
want to uh give that particular
impression about Zar in in general uh
and you'll notice also that I don't use
the the usual shocktober intro for the
video uh
partly as a result of that that that I
want to sort of stay away from from
giving too much of that impression so if
you want to see it as part of the whole
shock torbo thing then you you kind of
can I mean there's the candles and stuff
in the background still the whole
aesthetic is there but um at the same
time I felt like I need to point out
that um the Zod itself should not
be it's not part of shocktober in that
casee because of of Zar because of the
ritual but because of the general topic
of Jin possession um secondly uh I I
need to point out that because the
sources that I've used have primarily
focused on Egypt that means that the
information and the the the the stuff I
convey in the video is also uh mostly
particular to Egypt the general stuff
about Zar is true across the board but
there are some details that might differ
like for example I say that um most of
Zar practitioners are Muslim that's true
in Egypt I'm not entirely sure that's
necessarily true in Ethiopia for example
or the questions of gender that most
practitioners are women this is true in
in Egypt according to the sources but
I'm it could be true elsewhere too but I
just I I just also wanted to sort of put
that out there that I'm the details of
this stuff is particular to Egypt
because of the sources that I've used um
with all that said and with these
disclaimers in mind I hope you enjoyed
the
video
in my previous episodes we have
determined that belief in gin or spirits
in the Islamic and Middle Eastern world
is a widespread thing and also that it
is a common belief that such gin can
actually possess human
beings claimed cases of gin possession
while contested can be found across
history and in various places today and
when such a thing happens there are
different ways of dealing with it the
most common would be different forms of
Ria where the possessing spirit is
removed through rituals involving
quranic recitation or things like
amulets and talismans but in places like
Egypt there is an entirely different way
of dealing with Spirit possession that
have developed over the centuries and
which is known as Zar a kind of ritual
complex or tradition that involves
stories about spirits rituals to appease
those spirits and a whole ritual
Community built around the relation ship
between humans and the possessing gin
this is a tradition that involves many
different aspects and Fields of interest
from religion and mysticism SL Sufism to
music and dance to ritualization and and
and and social cohesion and social
belonging and it's a really fascinating
and prominent actually part of the
religious and ritual life of many people
in regions like like Egypt and and Sudan
and and Ethiopia so today let's dive
into the world of
[Music]
[Applause]
Zar
Zod is a widespread ritual complex that
is especially common today in the Red
Sea region such as in Egypt Ethiopia and
Sudan but also in places such as Arabia
and Iran essentially it is a tradition
of spirit possession and different ways
of dealing with it which includes
ecstatic music and dancing social groups
and a hierarchy of ritual Specialists
that aim to help people afflict icted
with spirits to ease their troubles and
get rid of the issue it's uncertain
where Zod originated with various
different theories and claims many claim
that it essentially originated in
Ethiopia and it seems certain enough
that it made its way into Egypt from
Ethiopia in particular around the early
19th century but others including in
Ethiopia itself will claim that it
actually comes from Yemen originally in
any case the earliest record of the word
Z being mentioned as referring to
possessing spirits come from a text in
gz in Ethiopia in the 16th century and
the earliest description of a Zod ritual
was also recorded in that country in the
early 19th century the word Zod is also
unclear in terms of its atmology and
origin it seems unlikely that it comes
from an Arabic word and there have been
various theories about it but in the
tradition we are talking about today the
word is used in a variety of different
ways in its most basic sense Zar is a
possessing Spirit a kind of being that
can possess human beings in the Islamic
context it has been categorized as a
specific type of Jin and sometimes in
particular would what is called the or
constant companion mentioned in the
Quran the Zar Spirits are numerous and
are often divided into lines of families
who live in societies just like human
beings and they can come into contact
with humans in different ways similar to
what we described in the previous
episode about General genin possession
these possessions can be the result of
various different things from uh somehow
offending uh the spirit in question or
encountering a particularly horny Spirit
In some cases or being the result of
some sort of occult or magical practice
at this point then one can become
possessed and the tradition describes
this through metaphors of of clothing so
this it's like the spirit is wearing the
person just like a person would would
wear clothes and this can result in
various different symptoms which
includes according to the scholar Hagar
hadidi quote headaches continuous
romatic pain weight loss nausea loss of
appetite infertility and
miscarriage a wide range of
psychological behaviors including
unexplainable bouts of anger and
aggression and states of sadness or fear
may also be symptomatic of Zar
possession
as we'll talk about a bit more later on
um certain behaviors and things that are
considered Taboo in these sociey such as
um homosexuality for instance could also
be connected to Zod possession in
different ways and cultic initiation
into the Zar ritual complex into the Zar
Community also serves in many ways as a
kind of way of of acceptance of these
social divergences so that is the basic
meaning of the word Zar as the name for
the possessing spirits that are at its
core but Zod is also used for the ritual
itself the ritual aimed at helping
people from possession as well as a
general name for the whole tradition or
complex itself when a person becomes
quote unquote worn by AAR Spirit they
refer to with words like ma Mar or menar
and since the symptoms are pretty
unpleasant You' of course want to get
rid of them if regular methods don't
help to alleviate their troubles and the
person suspects they might be dealing
with a zar possession they can then turn
to the Zar specialist and their rituals
Zod includes a whole hierarchy of
professionals and Specialists including
professional musicians a ritual
Specialist or leader is often referred
to as a she or she in the case of women
and indeed they are mostly women if a
person then thinks that they might be
afflicted with the Zar Spirit they will
go through a sometimes long process of
identifying the spirit in in question
you see the Zar Spirits are very much
individuals with personalities and
ethnicities and other things and AA can
use different sorts of incense play
different kinds of music or call upon
the spirit in different ways to make it
appear so to say through various kinds
of divination once the spirit is
identified The Afflicted person can then
enter into the Zar Community as you can
see it isn't just temporary rituals or
general ideas about the spirits but a
whole initiatory tradition you become
initiated into the Zar tradition and the
community and it is thus something that
stays with you for the rest of your life
unlike other types of Jin or other ideas
about Jin Zar Spirits cannot be
exercised in other words if you're
possessed by a by a zar Spirits this
means you're stuck with that spirit for
the rest of your life and this is
something that is really unique about
Zar in particular compared to other
forms of dealing with with gin
possession is that rather than trying to
get rid of the Gins that are possessing
people the Zar rituals and initiation is
instead aimed at um appeasing the
spirits and reconciliation with the
spirits when the initiate goes through
the initiation ritual incense will be
burned music will be played and animals
will be sacrificed after which the
initiate will isolate themselves for a
period eating only from this sacrificed
meat all this is in order to make the
spirit happy and reconcile it with the
host thereby removing the negative
effects of The Possession and hopefully
enhancing any positive effects that it
might have after this they have entered
into the Zar community and will continue
to do rituals regularly both in private
and with the community with the same
purpose in mind of keeping the spirit
happy there are various kinds of Zar
paraphernalia such as amulet or clothing
that might be worn because the
particular spirit that Is possessing
them enjoys those particular kinds of
clothes or or amulets or whatever like
we said the Zar Spirits have certain
personalities and likes there are
different kinds of Zar music for
instance and different spirits will
respond to different kinds of music
depending on its preferences this will
often be connected to their ethnicity or
nationality so that a spirit from Sudan
will respond to music and rhythms with
Sudanese Origins and so on
in terms of their public ritual this is
perhaps the most well-known aspect of
Zar usually on a weekly basis a zar
Community will meet for what is known as
hadra or gathering to perform a ritual
focused on music and dancing the Zar
Community has a whole host of
professional musicians who unlike the
congregation as a whole are usually male
and will specialize in different styles
and genres of music during the HRA
ecstatic music will be played and the
participant ANS can start dancing almost
uncontrollably like in a
trance this is seen as the possessing
Spirit taking over the person and
dancing to the particular kind of music
that they like for initiates this hadra
ritual is a way of keeping the spirits
Happy by playing their preferred music
and allowing it to take over by dancing
they are appeasing the spirit but the
hadra is also up to the public and many
non-initiates will participate as
audience members the most common purpose
for a non- initiate to participate is to
identify whether or not they are in fact
possessed by AAR spirit and to identify
the spirit in particular if they start
responding to a specific song then one
can more easily identify who it is
that's wearing you so to say since again
these are spirits have different
personalities and prefer different kinds
of music but others also just
participate because they are interested
uh they are curious they just want to
see the spectacle or perhaps they've
been invited by a friend for instance so
as you can see Zar represents a unique
and different way of dealing with genin
possession it's a complex ritual
tradition uh where initiated members
will continuously throughout their lives
perform these different rituals to
appease and reconcile with their Spirits
rather than to completely get rid of
them through exorcisms as you can
imagine Zar also serves a very
significant social function and role in
society where people who make maybe
don't fit in in different ways can find
a sense of social um belonging and
comfort it is worth pointing out and
indeed a very significant fact that the
vast majority of Zar practitioners and
initiates are women like we said the
professional musicians are often men but
the rest of the people connected to this
ritual complex are usually women the
ritual Specialist or sheas are mostly
women and it is women that are drawn to
become initiated there are men that
participate too of of course but they
are vastly outnumbered by women and even
then the men have come into contact with
Zar through wives sisters or in general
by hearing about it from women what are
the reasons for this what are some of
the psychological and social functions
and an aspect of Zar well it clearly
serves a social function to initiated
individuals who are going through
various Troubles by becoming part of a
fellowship where those experiences are
not necessarily shunned or attempted to
get rid of but rather to reconcile and
affirm many feelings and experiences
this becomes especially important for
women who after all have to go through
several difficult physical and mental
challenges throughout life that men are
usually spared indeed it has been
observed that instances of Zar spiritual
possessions often coincide with major
events in the lives of women such as
puberty and the first menstrual blood
marriage birthing and menopause these
events often come with certain crisis
for the person which can manifest as a
spirit
possession the purpose of Zara thus
partly becomes a kind of social support
network for women going through these
crises as well as to quote ground a
person in specific times and events
associated with Affliction and healing
in a way these Zar Spirits here become
almost like personifications of these
life crisis and anxieties and Zar
provides a clear way of embodying and
making those feelings real as well as
providing a path of healing through
reconciliation with this in mind it
becomes pretty clear why this phenomenon
is so common with women in the words of
hadidi quote the path of Zar provides a
technique for empowering and energizing
adapts particularly women to deal with
their lives by learning to listen to and
trust their feelings by drawing upon
their intuitive and innate powers of
imagination as well as their sensuous
experience and knowledge of the world as
we said Zar is quite a widespread
practice in places like Egypt and Sudan
and it is a significant albeit minor
aspect of the social fabric of these
societies its relationship to the wider
religious Traditions that dominate the
region is also an interesting Factor it
is true that many Muslims particularly
modernists have criticized Zar as unlam
as a kind of heresy and
stition at the same time the majority of
Zar practitioners are Muslim and often
devout practicing Muslims too it's also
quite common that Zar Affiliates are
also connected to Sufism since both have
come to represent a kind of traditional
form of religion or culture as opposed
to the modernist or fundamentalist
strands of Islam that have grown
stronger in the last century in short
Zar is a fascinating example of a spirit
possession tradition or ritual complex
that has some really unique and and
fascinating characteristics it
intersects with many other aspects of
religion and history and culture such as
questions of um gender and embodiment uh
trauma and and social belonging there is
of course so much more to say about Zar
and I have in no way done it justice in
this very short episode so as always I
encourage you to keep researching
yourself and I will also as always leave
sources and recommended readings in the
description when I am particularly
indebted to a spefic specific author or
book I like to give them a special shout
out and in this case I have based most
of this episode on the research and
writings of Hagar Al hadidi who has
written an excellent book called Zar
Spirit possession music and healing
rituals in Egypt this book is based on
her own research and personal
experiences and if you're interested in
the topic I can highly recommend this
book in particular and I will see you
next
time